an information gap can always be solved
by more data and when we looked on the
us market and we looked about the
residential market in the us there's so
much data everywhere you can know
basically everything you need to know
about a uh us property if you know where
to look and if you know where to buy
your data from and if you can utilize
this and use machine learning algorithms
and ai to take all this data and to
pinpoint exactly what you want to know
which in our case is the property value
the collateral it's the net operating
income the cash flow that comes from
this property you can get very accurate
results in a matter of seconds
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders and hello yairbinyamini
co-founder and ceo of landai
yair is the co-founder and ceo of lendai
prior to founding landai yaeur headed
the cross-border transactions and the
business development of one of israel's
leading law firms in that capacity he
took part in global multi-million dollar
transactions in north america europe
asia and the middle east gaire has more
than 15 years of experience leading
large-scale operations including in the
idf and several ngos here is also the
chairman of space girls and non-profit
organization promoting space and science
studies for young girls aiming to build
the next generation of women scientists
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
thank you for being here it's a pleasure
joining this uh
i was listening many times to the show
and now being here is uh it's a great
pleasure for me
well that's uh that's a huge honor for
me to hear so thank you very very much
you know you're working on some on some
really fascinating things in the fintech
space specifically leveraging ai to work
with with financing and lending for
foreign investors in the united states
residential markets you're using deep
technology to make the process seamless
and easy you know i go to the website
and immediately i see you know within 10
minutes you can see whether you're you
have the the right conditions to get to
get funding
from land i your company and so i'm
excited to dive deep into you know the
founding story of landai where you're at
today and a little bit more about the
domain that you're in and so perhaps
let's start there you take me back to
the founding of landai you're not coming
from the real estate space tangibly i
believe or the ai system tell me a
little bit about your transition there
and then how you how this company came
about
yeah so the easiest way to understand
with the story on how everything came
together so
around two and a half years ago uh boss
our cfo and one of the co-founders had a
conversation with a finance professor
from idc one of israeli universities
actually my school as well
and
they talked about foreign investment in
the u.s in europe boss and myself
together we met around the real estate
transaction in athens to be exact and
this professor told him that he has
three single family properties in the us
and he even has a bank account in chase
from the sabbatical year that he did
and once we last visit in the us it was
pre-covered we wanted to buy more
properties but this time said well
i'm done with buying all cash let's get
into the bank and get a mortgage so you
knock on the door open chase where he
has his account say hi i want to buy
more properties here where do i need to
sign the mortgage that's all i need to
do and this banker just looked at him
smiled like a yes banker knows how to do
then well we know the properties here
just well we know how to evaluate them
how to put a lien on them how to
foreclose them if we need to how to sell
them afterwards basically we know
everything we need to know about the us
property we have a slight problem and
it's you you have no credit scoring here
you don't know who you are in your
origin country as far as aml kyc
processes goes what are you saying
israel is on the map he said somewhere
in the middle east i don't even know
where it is actually so thank you but no
thanks you won't see a dollar from us
when he came back to israel before you
continue with the story i just want to
pause here for a second because we hear
the story a lot about you know
foreigners coming to the united states
no credits for no credit system no
background making it difficult why can't
just give me a little bit of an overview
why is the u.s system based on this on
this idea of background checks why is it
so important for the bank as a lender to
to be considerate of your background
before they make this landing process
so basically every every lender whether
it's a bank or a private lender need to
mitigate this risk and when you become a
new client even
more if it's not a client that works
with you on a day-to-day basis so you
don't you don't get if it's not a us
residence so it's it doesn't have a w-2
it doesn't get a seller in the u.s
you as a lender or a bank just doesn't
know enough about him so the credit
scoring system is a tool for them to use
say okay there's some other guy that is
evaluating this person he gives them a
score i know that they have a good
algorithm they have a good system
i for the one who sees this client for
the first time i can count on this
system and it makes me
easier to to decide basically it's
mitigating my risk because i know okay
he has a 800 points sql score
what can go wrong somebody checked him
before i did and it was okay now i will
do my double check and i will make sure
that everything is fine but i already
know that i'm talking with a good client
when someone comes with poor credit
scoring or no credit scoring
it's just almost impossible for the bank
to evaluate the risk so then if he needs
to
put all his effort into let's say if an
israeli or a german guy or a chinese
coming with his bank statement in his
origin country language who knows how to
read chinese in a us-based bank or
german and or right and the process is
just too long and it's too much of a
hassle for them and it doesn't matter if
it's a car loan
mortgage a credit card you see this
problem going all the way into the
industry and there's different types of
fintech lenders and think the companies
each one of them is targeting a
different audience of those
thin file no credit for investors name
it
however you want to
because the u.s system is based on those
fico scores and those credit scoring
there's so much good people that are
just left out outside of the credit
system
uh in the ordinary day-to-day life
right
so so go back now to the funding story
so now that we understand this problem
it'll give a little bit more context as
to how you're actually going about
solving it because you're actually
leveraging deep technology to to
sort of bypass a lot of a lot of these
issues exactly so just to finish the
story so after he came back from back
from the u.s to israel in this case
and he said in the u.s they told him no
he came back to his back to illumi bank
in tel aviv
and you tell hey i'm a client in the
bank i want to get a mortgage to buy
more properties in the us the israeli
banker told them the exact opposite they
told them well we know you just fine you
have a great salary from the university
you're a client of this bank for many
years we would love to work with you but
we have a small problem we have no way
how to evaluate how to foreclose how to
take a property overseas so thank you
but no thanks you won't see a shekel
from us
and that's the problem that we're
solving and the same problem goes with a
canadian investor buying the us a
mexican over the border coming to the
u.s or german or of course for any other
place in the world
once we realize this problem is existing
it was after the school where that was
held with the guy we said it was 2019
and how come it could be that this
informational gap is causing this
financial gap when we're talking about a
good investment property in the us a
good foreign investor because it's
someone that have enough money in his
origin country to go and diversify this
portfolio to the us we're not talking
about someone from the street we're
talking about high net individuals mass
affluent clients people that have money
those are good clients and in their
origin country everybody loves them in
the banking system in the us nobody
knows them
once we understand this we thought how
can we solve this problem and the idea
that we came up with we said in 2019 an
information gap can always be solved by
more data and when we looked on the us
market and we looked at the residential
market in the us
there's so much data everywhere you can
know basically everything you need to
know about a us property if you know
where to look and if you know where to
buy your data from and if you can
utilize this and use machine learning
algorithms and ai to take all this data
and to pinpoint exactly what you want to
know which in our case is the property
value is a collateral it's the net
operating income the cash flow that's
coming from this property you can get
very accurate results in a matter of
seconds and from the other side a u.s
bank that group is looking on a foreign
investor doesn't know exactly what to do
but if you know how to assess
a client in his origin country based on
information from his origin country so
we know how to assess the canadian based
on canadian information the uk guy on a
information from london the israeli guy
from tel aviv and if you know how to
take all this information and put it
into one system that is basically an
underwriting and a pricing machine that
evaluates the property value the
property and ui and the foreign investor
credit scoring you can get what we call
a point of sale mortgage based on this
triple digital underwriting system
this system is what enabling us to get a
point of sale mortgage
because you talked about 10 minutes it
takes around three minutes to get a loan
offer not even 10 minutes and
the guy can sit in his home in montreal
in toronto or in sydney and get a loan
offer fully online say i accept and
gonna move forward doing the entire
process based on our platform and from
application to processing and closing
even the signing of the mortgage
documents everything goes on the online
sphere and you can get a loan of 300 000
dollars on your portfolio in ohio when
these sits on the couch in tel aviv for
example and this is basically what our
technology is enabling us to do
so now obviously here there's a sort of
chicken and dig problem you're talking
about building a model that is able to
assess and mitigate those risks but what
i'm what i'm considering here is you
know how do you actually prove that the
model works because you know until you
actually
lent somebody money and saw that they're
able to pay it back and you don't know
whether you've done a good job so how
how how do you go about as the leader of
this organization think critically about
okay when are we ready with our own
model to go and actually use this to
predict
the the the chances of of our clients
paying back the mortgage
so first of all due to the diversity of
our funding system funding team we have
ellis dicker who is our cto he's a 33
year veteran from the tech side of the
banking system he build credit scoring
system and origination system in the
israeli banking system we have team elon
of wizard chief data science who is 15
years in the fintech industry
hall is doing they
dusted down is just building ai
algorithms in the high frequency
algorithm ecosphere in the property
value aircraft in the last few years and
we have bosnic guitar cfo was the
sec the head of the credit market the
capital sector in the third largest bank
in israel so we have a team that knows
how to evaluate risk we took all this
knowledge put it into the machine and
put it into the platform
and because we wanted to show that we
know what we're doing the first
mortgages we issued we issued from our
own capital we gave our own money to our
investors to the foreign investors based
on the algorithms that we built and from
the second mortgage actually and in
onwards the banks were on board with us
gave us the credit lines and i think
we're maybe the first fintech lending
company that as of the second mortgage
that it gave or the second loan they
gave it was already bank
debt uh and it's not because we have
pretty eyes because we have good
reputation we have great collaterals and
br and we built a very smart and easy to
use system that the banks can just
understand how it works but not just
that we're not a solution because if i
would need to go to let's say wells
fargo say hey take this mechanism and
build it into your own system it's a
cell cycle that takes years this is why
we decide to be the owner originator
ourselves and we take the risk and once
we show that the risk is okay and
mitigate in a good way
now all the big banks that we work with
or and funds that give us the funding
are just know that we know how to
deliver because we showed it and we
proved the model time after time
all right and so
i'm imagining that one of the big goals
of the company is to be the go-to place
for foreign investors to come to get to
get this margin mortgage and to get this
financing and so it's a question of
scale and and one of the kpis is
probably to get more and more customers
on board and how do you then
strategically think about doing that how
do you know when to when when to push it
when to hold back when to evaluate what
is sort of the thinking process that you
go with
so i totally agree with you and when we
started building the company we thought
what type of model do we want to build
is this a b2c company and if it's if it
was a b2c company how do we get to
hundreds of thousands of foreign
investors work that are spreading
worldwide and this is why we chose to be
a b2b2c type of business so we have a
huge partnership networks we work with
realtors loan brokers property managers
developers uh entrepreneurs everybody
that has a us operation working in the
real estate industry in the us and sell
or manage or working with for investors
they get from us a system that they can
use either to manage your portfolio and
with a click of a button to connect
their clients to our loans so basically
what we're doing we're financing their
clients and empowering them because once
their clients have more money they can
do more transactions with them so it's a
very simple easy to use win-win
situation system they bring the clients
we bring the money and everybody makes
more
and this is why we can get into
thousands to tens of thousands of
potential clients from 100 partners that
we have and we're getting new ones every
day
so so far it sounds like a true
cinderella story but where's the poop
well what's been really challenging in
your journey you know from the get-go
into where you came to now
so it took us we started working on in
2019 we launched the platform in 2021
and we work full-time all the time just
to build the infrastructure basically
because we couldn't take anything
off the market say okay there's a loan
origination system let's take it and use
it because the questions that are an
american origination system asking are
not relevant to the foreign investor and
if we're looking on our algorithm let's
say zero our algorithm evaluating a
property value it's looking on the
property as an investment property so it
looks how money does it worth today and
how high it will go but what we are
looking on is how low it will never go
because it's a collateral it's not an
investment so we have to build
everything from scratch
from the legal side of it this is i'm a
lawyer by profession and no one no one's
perfect so i spend hours and hours and
hundreds of hours just to build the
right
legal structure to make sure that we can
operate in an easy way and to scale from
state to state now we're opening a new
state in the u.s probably every three to
four weeks uh if we haven't built the
right
legal network and legal system this
couldn't be happened so
there
it's it's a it's a it's a watch with a
lot of variables and a lot of tools and
and screws inside of it
and we have to make sure that everything
is work
fully automatically inside of it this is
where we four founders you don't see
many many indie companies or other
companies that have four founders
each one of us has
10 to 30 years of experience in this
field efforts but this because what
we're doing is very complex
knock on wood we're succeeding
now a little bit more personally about
you so you've been in the legal space
for quite some time you you've you've
managed
very significant deals
and you know you said you launched this
you found the company in 2019 launched
in 2021
what happened in 2019 that you decide
that it's time for you to become an
entrepreneur to become a co-founder with
other three folks to build a company
what what was it a sudden decision was
it a lengthy process for you so it was a
lengthy process i was working as a
lawyer i loved what i do
and i was actually in the middle of
negotiation becoming a partner in the
law firm that i worked i i actually had
the agreement and i gave like notes if
there changed this change that and then
i met boss
came to me with the story of the idea
around this transaction
and you know when sometimes something
just click you said this is the right
person
i'm
it's either being a lawyer for the rest
of my life or trying to do something
else now and two weeks later i put in a
notice and left the firm within good
terms but
i said goodbye
and we found in landai and a few weeks
later wasn't i said said we need to
build a tax system here so he called
us told hey i'm just today i'm leaving
the bank after 33 years said great let's
meet tomorrow the next day he joined
and tim was actually working there and
he said team come and join us maybe be
the first employee they said you know
what they changed something on the
company that i work in they're they're
changing the technology he was the head
of rnd in a high frequency training
company i'm looking for something new
i'm coming i'm joining and then we just
said okay but just
everybody join and from this day onwards
we're working together
uh and boss was the glue that gave the
bring all of us together was was working
with errors in the banking system with
team you know on his last uh fintech
company that they had and with me on
this real estate transaction so buzz
just collected good people from all
kinds of places and
the rest is history as we say
so it is you do you have a prior
relationship with the fintech space
specifically
foreign investments ai based solutions
or is this something that you grew into
as a part of your role as co-founder and
ceo of this company
so many things i learned as an
entrepreneur investing in the us is
something that i did as a lawyer as a as
a foreign investor myself so i knew the
problem as a as a lawyer i managed a lot
of transactions in the us for israelis
for some european companies so i knew
the market i knew the cross-border
transaction market i did it with
cannabis farms in canada hospitals in
china
and many other
kinds of transactions so i knew the era
and i knew how real estate in the us is
working out i'm married to an american
girl
um so so we have family in florida and
we're just moving to florida actually
next month
um so i knew the market i just needed to
connect the dots with the technology
into that and say okay this is the
problem this is how the market is
working how can we solve it with
technology
and
i'm glad to say that this is what we
managed to do in the last two years
i love it yeah i want to take you back
to your childhood and go back and
understand a little bit you better what
really fascinated you as a child what
really sparked your curiosity so as a
child i raised in the golan heights
inside the not far north of israel
i'm a far coming from a farmer family we
raise mangoes and bananas and whatever
you want to
uh basically as a child that was so far
from the tech world i was
raising you know uh
kite surfing on the kinetic in the golan
in the sea of galilee
i was working in the fields with my
family
i was so far from this tech world after
i finished the army it was for quite a
few years in the army as an officer
today as well i'm a major i'm a company
commander in the israeli special forces
and i came to the celia to the idc to
start learning and once i opened to the
world of what happens you know in in in
the city let's call it like this and i
saw where technology can take people
i was just amazed and i said this is
where i want to be 10 years later this
is where i am this is where i am with my
family
and i just love the ecosystem
but it's very far from where i begin and
to where i am today
that's what it sounds like and so if you
look in your day today right now what
what what inspires you whether it's a
specific event or something that's
ongoing
so it's the small success that we see
you know a client that says hey you
solve the problem that i have for many
years i have portfolio of properties and
i i tried everybody told me no and we
know he's a good client it's working
with the team this is what i always
wanted and part of the reason why i left
being a lawyer
is because being a lawyer is is a very
soul you get yourself the computer
you're managing a transaction maybe
working with an intern or two
but i i'm an army guy i like to have all
my team in a row and charging on the
enemy or on the market whatever and this
is what you do in the startup you put
everybody in line and just running
forward together and i really wanted to
be part of a team
and this is what i am today i'm a part
of a team of amazing people and i just
you know we work 18 hours a day but we
do it with a smile
i love it i love it and what are three
words you would use to describe yourself
that's a good question
so i'm very positive and i think i
couldn't be an entrepreneur if i wasn't
hopelessly positive
that as my wife will tell who will say
it
i'm very much trying to be uh
multidisciplinary so i know i know where
i came from i know what i know today and
on the road i learned how to manage
people how to work
how to develop businesses how to manage
funds so i'm very very much
multi-disciplined this is why i went to
the idc to learn multiple things so i
learned law and government and business
and many other things
and i'm very determined uh once i set my
mind on something
nothing will stop me
i love it yeah thank you very very much
best of luck with landai and i can't
wait to see this company grow and
continue
following your journey and i really
appreciate the time and stay safe and
stay healthy thank you very much stay
safe as well and good luck for uh people
and and the success for the team
thank you pleasure being here thank you
very much